et notre invité politique ce matin ces
manuels bompard bonjour merci beaucoup
d'athlètes nos directeurs de campagne de
jean luc mélenchon on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par stéphane bern et de
ouest france bonjour stéphane bonjour
bonjour bonjour on va évidemment parler
de cet entre deux tours mais d'abord le
résultat de jean luc mélenchon manuel
bompard finalement
vous êtes un peu plus de quatre cent
mille voix aller du second tour c'est un
score historiquement haut pour la france
a soumis ce qu'est ce qui vous a manqué
pour franchir la marche c'est toujours
difficile de savoir qu'est ce qui vous a
manqué il faut faire le bilan et
regarder la réalité de les personnes des
personnes qui se sont déplacées dimanche
et c'est lui qui se sont pas déplacés on
est en train de faire ce travail mais
honnêtement on est partagé entre une
déception est légitime et compréhensible
je pense quand on est candidat à une
élection présidentielle l'objectif c'est
de se qualifier au deuxième tour on n'a
pas réussi et en même temps une fierté
fierté pour le score réalisé fierté
aussi pour avoir réussi à se faire
déplacer dimanche partie importante de
la genèse des catégories populaires des
gens qui allaient plus voté par fois
depuis 5 ans 10 ans 15 ans et qu'on
retrouvait autour de la candidature de
jean luc mélenchon des raisons d'espérer
donc c'est je préfère retenir la fierté
parce que c'est sur cette fierté qu'on
pourra construire les victoires de
demain vous en voulez tout
particulièrement à aux communistes et à
fabien roussel qui étaient les
communistes et autres alliés en 2010 700
e jean luc mélenchon est le deuxième
tour en tout cas c'est mathématique
c'est à dire que le nombre de voix
réalisé par fabien roussel est supérieur
à l'écart qui nous manque pour nous
qualifier
je ne sais pas et je vais vous dire
franchement en partie en tout cas en
partie sans doute nous nous avons fait
le choix dans cette campagne ne pas
réagir aux aux invectives parfois y
compris aux caricatures qu'on pu faire
les autres candidats de gauche à jean
leclant choses pas aujourd'hui que je
vais commencer à le faire on est on est
quand même dans une phase de tension là
entre autres qu entre les militants
communistes et insoumis notamment sur
les réseaux sociaux ça bah je comprends
les sentiments comme l'assuré je me
comprendre écouter quand vous êtes en
campagne depuis 18 mois avec l'objectif
de qualifier votre candidat au deuxième
tour et que vous avez l'impression que
ça se joue un cheveu et que ce cheveu
pour partie s'appelle fabien roussel bah
oui forcément on est déjà assez puisque
pas pardon sa peine ce que vous visez
évidemment le vote des classes
populaires les classes populaires et se
sont aussi en grande partie tourner vers
marine le pen comment vous l'expliquez
vrai pourquoi parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
colère dans ce pays que le quinquennat
d'emmanuel macron dont lui-même s'était
fixé un objectif je le rappelle qui
était de réduire la place de l'extrême
on adore ce pays de ce point de vue là a
été un échec et oui à des gens qui sont
en colère et quand on est en colère on
cherche un bulletin de vote une
candidature qui expriment cette colère
alors pour partie
s'est pas totalement sa passe que pour
partie on a réussi à convaincre un
certain nombre de personnes que
effectivement c'est plutôt les
propositions formulées par jean luc
mélenchon qui était de nature à
améliorer la situation on n'a pas réussi
à convaincre tout le monde bat ça c'est
un combat de longue haleine qu'on va
continuer à amener bien évidemment juste
pour terminer avec fabien roussel et
communistes là maintenant vous allez
devoir aussi discuté dans le cadre des
législatives est ce que est ce que vous
allez pouvoir vous entendre après cet
épisode bah forcément je vais pas vous
dire que le ressentiment ne rend pas les
choses un peu plus compliqué mais je
crois qu'il va falloir faire en sorte
que pour les élections à venir qui vont
avoir un finalement un rôle quasiment de
troisième tour parce que l'élection
présidentielle de mon point de vue on va
régler aucune des grandes questions
auxquelles est confronté ce pays et donc
les élections législatives de ce point
de vue là elles vont avoir une
importance fondamentale et bien sûr moi
je dis à toutes celles et ceux qui
veulent participer à la construction
sans doute d'un dieu d'un pacte
majoritaire pour les élections
législatives je leur dis que il va
falloir discuter mais il va falloir
discuter autour de la candidature autour
du programme autour des orientations
politiques qui ont été choisis par les
électrices et les électeurs au premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle donc
autour du bassin venir discuter autour
de vous bah ça me paraît évident ça veut
pas dire c'est tout à prendre ou à
laisser bien sûr qu'on peut discuter
mais ça veut dire qu'il ya une
centralité de l'orientation politique
qui autour desquels doit organiser le
rassemblement qui est celle qui a été
porté par jeunes et d'anciens officiers
d'une grosse partie de vote utile mais
bien sûr jour je l'entends mais mais
mais mais je crois que
si on tient compte de deux ça bien sûr
qu'il faut en tenir compte et c'est
pourquoi je vous dis qu'il va falloir
sans aucun doute discuter pour autant il
me semble qu il est très évident est
très claire dans les résultats tels
qu'ils apparaissent eux qui sont
apparues dimanche soir que l'orientation
politique générale au tour de kate doit
se faire ce rassemblement c'est une
orientation une rupture sur les
questions sociales et économiques de
prise en compte de l'urgence climatique
et c'est le programme qui a été porté
par jean luc on va revenir sur les
législatives un peu plus tard on va
rester dans cet entre-deux-tours puisque
vous êtes la clé de ce second tour c'est
vers vous vers votre électorat que les
deux candidats ce ton ça vous donne une
responsabilité quand même la
responsabilité dans une élection quand
il ya plus que deux candidats allaient
d'abord dans les mains des deux
candidats c'est à dire que si certains
veulent s'adresser à un électorat notre
électorat aux gens qui ont voté pour
nous qui ne nous appartiennent pas par
ailleurs
qu'il le fasse mais je crois que
là l'enjeu de la question sociale telle
qu'elle a été portée par jean luc
mélenchon doit être effectivement un
enjeu de cette campagne de deuxième
temps j'ai entendu le président de la
république dire par exemple que sur la
question des retraites il était prêt à
faire des aménagements bah maintenant
moi je dis qu'il dise clairement les
choses c'est ce que vous attendez je
sais pas là pour négocier avec emmanuel
macron
s'adresser à nos électeurs juba par
exemple il a ouvert la porte un faire un
dogme sur les retraites qu'il le dise
clairement qu'ils prennent un engagement
parce que si brun engagement sans doute
que ça peut intéresser des électeurs qui
ont voté pour jean luc mélenchon parce
qu'ils sont pas d'accord avec le fait
qu'on amène l'âge de départ à la
retraite à 65 ans je donne cet exemple
il peut y en avoir d'autres il faut pas
faire de 2,2 d'élèves de choses pas
claires parce que là
il est pour l'instant non je trouve que
moi j'ai pas compris où il était prêt à
aller il a dit oui je suis prêt à faire
un référendum comme sur l'ensemble des
sujets qui laisse clairement les choses
qui est clair c'est qu'il a besoin d'une
partie des voix de vos électeurs du
premier tour
bah alors lorsqu'il leur temps qu'il
essaie de leur tendre la main en
aménageant un seul argument son
programme leur parle clairement ce sera
par exemple sur la réforme des retraites
hier il a dit qu'il ouvrait la porte
un roc un rapport à 64 ans et non plus
65 65 finalement c'était plus un totem
est ce que ça c'est un premier pas qui
vous convient je crois que il va falloir
qu'ils comprennent que quand on a voté
pour jean luc mélenchon c'est à dire
pour le retour à la retraite à 60 ans
clairement il peut pas être question
d'accepter l'idée qu'on passe la
retraite à 63 64 65 ans donc à mon avis
le sujet n'est pas le le l'âge le niveau
auquel on va le mettre c'est que si
emmanuel macron veut tenir compte de la
configuration particulière de ce
deuxième tour c'est à dire du fait que
pour l'emporter il doit avoir des
électeurs qui se porte sur lui pour
autant alors qu'ils n'adhèrent pas à son
projet il doit accepter l'idée que sur
un certain nombre de sujets il devra
s'en remettre aux françaises et aux
français aussi dit clairement il y aura
un référendum sur la réforme des
retraites ça vous ira ça sera
le programme annuel macro n'est pas
celui que je partage vous entendez bien
c'est
la question de savoir si c'était
efficace pour parler aux électrices et
aux électeurs qu porté leurs suffrages
sur jean luc mélenchon il me semble que
ce serait plus malins logique de sa part
de dire qu'il s'engage clairement sur un
effet un homme sinon les sur son cas
d'autres points ce que vous aimeriez
qu'il qu'il évolue en plus rock en plus
de la retraite écoutez franchement moi
mon sujet si vous voulez il ya peu de
compatibilité entre le programme de jean
les cochons et le programmes des manuels
macro ne veux pas vous dire ici que si
vous l'entendez reprendre le terme de
planification quand vous les entendez
dire hier qu'il fallait mettre plus
d'écologie dans son projet est-ce que ça
c'est une bonne jaffe cinq ans qui dit
qu'il faut mettre plus d'écologie dans
son projet puis après quand on passe et
quand on arrive aux actes moi ce qui
m'intéressait pas les grandes
déclarations vous voyez c'est les actes
concrets donc qu'ils prennent des
engagements en matière écologique dans
le programme de jean luc mélenchon il y
avait la volonté d'inscrire dans la
constitution ce qu'on appelle la règle
verte celeron prend pas davantage à la
planète chaque année que ce qu'elle est
capable de régénérer
est ce qu'il est prêt à s'avancer dans
cette direction qu'est-ce qui fait
concernant les accords de libre échange
est ce qu'il est prêt à avancer pour une
forme de protectionnisme solidaire est
ce qu'il est prêt à aller sur la
comptine sont pour son bios et gratuite
à l'école voilà des mesures concrètes
pas des grandes phrases grandes
déclarations parce que pardonnez-moi
mais les grandes phrases et les grandes
déclarations d' emmanuel macron il ya
plus grand monde qu'ils y croient dans
ce pays donc maintenant faut prendre des
engagements concrets
bon jean luc mélenchon a été très clair
au sort du premier tour donc pas une
voix pour marine le pen comment est-ce
que vous personnellement vous allez
interpréter ça moi - mon vote il restera
forcément se créer c'est pourquoi
forcément parce que c'est la beauté du
vote c'est pour ça qu'on a inventé des
isoloirs qu'il ya des enveloppes pour
mettre son bulletin donc je garderai
bien évidemment mon vote pour moi je
mélange chansons mais bien sûr mais je
l'interprète de la manière suivante sur
les cochons a dit à trois reprises pas
ils nous voient qu'on le rassemblement
est réglé je ne donnerai pas une voix
qu'on leur rassemblement national quelle
manière exactement de le faire
j'utiliserai je verrai en tout cas en
tout état de cause si j'irai voter parce
qu'il me semble que c'est important
d'aller voter et ensuite le choix que je
ferai pas je le ferai en conscience
non je crois pas à faire le jeu de
madame le pen c'est voter pour madame le
pen il peut pas en être question pour le
reste il ya parmi les électrices et les
électeurs qui ont porté leurs suffrages
sur jean luc mélenchon des avis
différents sur ce point et pour être
tout à fait clair et honnête je les
respecte tous et je compris on va
regarder parce qu'un partenaire ipsos
tremplin serrait justement à étudier le
report de voix les électeurs de m
mélenchon 62% de vos électeurs vont vers
l'abstention en trois vers emmanuel
macron 15 vers marine le pen qu'est ce
que vous leur dites à ces 15% d'abord je
dis soyons vigilants sur ces enquêtes
parce que au soir du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle de 2017 y
avait des enquêtes de même nature au
final on a constaté que moins de 10% des
électeurs qui s'étaient portés pour
jouer les conventions 2017 s'était porté
sur marine le pen au deuxième tour jeudi
vigilance avec ses enquêtes pour le
reste je ne conteste pas le fait qu'il
puisse y avoir des gens qui aient voté
pour jean les coins chauds premier toit
et qui s'interrogent au deuxième tour et
qui envisagent même l'hypothèse de voter
pour marine le pen je leur dis je vous
respecte mais à mon avis si vous faites
ça c'est une erreur parce que vous vous
trompez pas ce que vous pensez que
madame le pen va défendre vos intérêts
alors que ce n'est pas le cas parce que
par exemple madame le pen sur les
retraites elle a abandonné la
revendication de la retraite à 60 ans
pour tout le monde que madame le pen est
opposé à l'augmentation du smic comme un
homme le pen est opposée par exemple aux
blocs des prix sur les produits de
première nécessité alors que ce serait
une mesure indispensable comme madame le
pen ne dit rien sur la manière de
répondre à l'urgence climatique et
qu'elle peut en aucun cas être une
solution mais je le fais dans le débat
dans le dialogue dans la conviction pas
en donnant des consignes pendant
n'obligeant pas en contraignant parce
que ça ne marchera pas voilà comment
sont les retraites est ce que votre
position n'est pas plus proches de
celles de marine
malheureusement sans doute puisque
madame le pen n'est pas pour la retraite
à 65 ans en tout cas elle ne l'a pas
exprimé comme tel mais je ne suis
d'accord ni avec le projet de madame le
pen y avec le projet des manuels macro
sur le sujet et c'est d'ailleurs la
raison pour laquelle je suis déçu de ce
deuxième tour parce que je considère que
ce deuxième tour ne va pas régler ces
grandes questions et c'est pourquoi je
dis aussi rester mobilisés parce que
quelle que soit la personne qu'ils
l'emportent à l'élection présidentielle
on aura une responsabilité particulière
à l'élection législative donc il faudra
faire en sorte d'avoir un poids qui soit
un poids important est qu'on va revenir
sur les justes emmanuel macron hier il a
dit qu'il avait changé avec avec jean
luc mélenchon est comme ça bien sûr je
le sais et je dois vous dire que je
trouve que les la méthode des bagnoles
ma peau et est très déplacé très
déloyale puisque jean luc mélenchon et
emmanuel macron ont effectivement
échanger sur le sort d'une personne qui
aujourd'hui est un opposant politique
dans un autre pic et menacé de mort et
donc jean luc mélenchon a échangé pour
le essayer de faire en sorte qu'ils
puissent être exfiltré en quelque sorte
de son pays ça n'a strictement rien à
voir avec le deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle et faire croire comme le
faisait emmanuel macron qu'en fait
c'était une manière de discuter ou de
négocier est tout à fait déloyal et je
lui dis attention parce que c'est pas
comme ça pas avec ce type de méthode et
de procéder vous allez convaincre nos
électeurs de se reporter sur vous au
deuxième tour de l'élection prévue lundi
qu'il allait échanger avec tous les
candidats est éliminée est ce que jean
luc mélenchon échangera avec lui sur
cette question de l'entrain de nom le
débat et la discussion elle doit se
faire de manière publique et jean luc
mélenchon en dira quand il en aura envie
si les envies d'ailleurs de revenir sur
le deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle pour l'instant il a parlé
dimanche et il me semble que ce qu'il a
dit était suffisamment clair
mais l'idée quand je marche je sais pas
jean l'écolo chauffera bien ce qu'il
veut c'est pas moi qui tient son
téléphone vous voyez mais en tout cas il
n'y a pas grand chose à se dire un
dernier point à des questions plus
politiques la cfdt appelle à voter pour
m et le maquereau le medef fait de même
en disant que le programme du candidat
macro est le plus favorable pour
l'économie comment est ce que vous
prenez ça vous
je prends la cfdt a toujours une
position entre traditionnel qui était de
2 d'appeler à abattre l'extrême droite
au deuxième tour ça a toujours été ça sa
position qu'on sait que le medef
soutiennent
ça me surprend pas une séparation
c'est pas un scoop pour moi que le medef
considère que le programme des manuels
maquerelle plus favorable à l'économie
française je ne partage pas d'ailleurs
l'avis du medef mais on peut en débattre
d'ailleurs jean les conventions avaient
débattu avec le président du medef je
crois que c'était un débat intéressant
il ya eu peu de débat intéressant dans
cette campagne mais celui-là l'été moi
c'est pas une surprise pour moi et et
voilà on parlait de la suite c'était
vraiment la dernière campagne de
jean-luc mélenchon la dernière campagne
présidentielle c'est ce qu'il a dit
après la dernière campagne ça y prendra
sa décision notamment au regard des des
élections qui viennent des échéances
électorales à venir il peut être
intéressant qu'il le peut comme il peut
ne pas être et je crois qu'il doit
prendre il a déjà pris sa décision je
vois pas à ma connaissance et puis c'est
lui qui le dira quand il a envie de le
dire c'est normal que ce soit à lui de
le faire en tout cas jean luc mélenchon
va pas disparaître demain
la scène mais il aura un rôle central
écouter quand vous avez été le troisième
candidat plus de 20% 20 près de 22% des
voix à l'élection présidentielle vous
êtes un acteur politique majeur de
premier plan et je crois je crois que la
force politique qui s'est constituée
autour de la candidature de jean luc
mélenchon c'est la force politique
autour de laquelle va s'organiser la
recomposition politique à gauche et jean
luc le savez moi j'ai fini saint
soumises bonjour l'union populaire bas
la france est soumise ne va pas
disparaître mais le cas donc a été mis
en place deux regroupements de
rassemblement qui s'appelle lune et au
populaire a vocation à s'élargir vous me
posiez la question vous me posez la
question tout à l'heure du rapport aux
autres formations politiques qui ne se
sont pas présentés avec nous au premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle moi je
dis à celles et ceux qui sont déçus qui
parfois sont restés dans des logiques un
peu d'appareils je leur dis vous êtes
les bienvenus dans un cadre quel cadre
de l'union populaire puisque ce cadre a
fait la démonstration de son efficacité
dans cette élection comme maintenant il
faut l'élargir qu'ils soient présents
dans l'ensemble des échéances
électorales prochaines à venir qui sont
engagés aussi dans les mobilisations
sociales dans la résistance aux mauvais
coups qui vont venir de la part du
président andré de la république qui va
être élu dans quelques jours on a besoin
de cette force politique et jeudi à la
jeunesse en particulier aux quartiers
populaires à toutes celles et ceux qui
se sont mobilisés vous avez un outil
maintenant vous avez un outil qui porte
votre espoir de l'espérance votre colère
eh bien venez venez l'aider à le
renforcer le rejoindre et c'est vous qui
prenait la suite à la tête de la france
a soumises jean luc mélenchon vous a
donné les clés du camion à marseille non
il y avait un peu de ça on a écouté jean
luc mélenchon sont d'abord ne donne pas
les clefs du camion pour l'instant
premièrement et deuxièmement je vais les
donner quand est-ce qu'il va sauver mais
mais les choses ne sont pas aussi simple
que ça vous savez est il forcément je
veux dire les prêts mais bien sûr mais
je veux dire les choses de cette manière
jean luc mélenchon a contribué à faire
émerger dans le paysage politique
une vingtaine de personnes deux figures
du maintenant pas totalement identifié
mais qui sont identifiés par une partie
des françaises et des français
nécessairement l'avenir elle se
construira autour de ces différentes
personnes j'en fais partie sans aucun
doute mais je ne suis pas seul et je
pense qu'on travaillera collectivement à
faire grandir cette force moi je suis
conscient aussi de ce qui a été notre
atout dans cette élection présidentielle
est ce qui a été notre atout dans le
cette élection présidentielle c'est
notre cohérence notre unité et ben cette
cohérence et cette unité on va faire en
sorte de la préserver parce que ça va
toujours leader trois candidats arrivés
en tête sont les trois candidats qui
avaient un leader et d'anti bien sûr
est-ce que vous pouvez continuer avec un
collectif est ce que il fallait
quelqu'un pour prendre clairement la
supplique jean luc mélenchon et
s'imposer finalement dans le plus
clairement et quand il y a des échéances
électorales futures elles sont dans
quelques années qu'ils sont telles dans
les institutions de la vème république
quand ils sont incarnés par un candidat
ou une candidate
et bien évidemment nous nous mettrons en
ordre de bataille pour faire en sorte
qu'une personne représente ce courant
politique pour les prochaines échéances
mais soyons un peu prudent et on a le
temps on en est pas là encore c'est dans
cinq ans je crois que ce serait un peu
indécent aujourd'hui de commencer à
préparer les élections présidentielles
de 2000 27 avant les élections
présidentielles de 2000 27,6 à les
législatives du mois de juin là je pense
que c'est une grosse c'est une grosse
échéance ainsi est-ce que vous êtes déjà
en train de me préparer ou autrement dit
avec qui est ce que vous négociez pour
des accords en fait circonscription par
circonscription pour ces législatives
d'abord on les prépare en interne oui ça
veut dire qu'on a identifié ce qu'on a
appelé des chefs de file sur l'ensemble
des circonscriptions du pays on a
couvert à peu près 400 circonscription à
ce stade on a coutume vous aurez des
candidats d' identifier la france en
misant 405 entraîneur pour l'instant ce
sont des chefs de file accord suit ses
chefs de file peuvent être candidat
comme finalement si il y à des
discussions qui aboutissent à des
accords de rassemblements ces candidats
dans ce cas là ne seront pas forcément
candidat honnêtement on n'en est pas
encore là on a besoin de faire le point
sur les résultats du premier projet
l'élection ce sera d'avoir des candidats
partout ou pas bach notre objectif pour
être très clair c'est que à partir du
moment où on considère que l'élection
présidentielle ne règle pas les grandes
questions la question qui se pose à la
législative c'est la question du pouvoir
et pas uniquement la question de
constituer un petit groupe d'opposition
la question est de savoir si on est en
capacité de se battre pour participer au
construire une majorité alternative
c'est ça la question qui va être posée
aux élections législatives et pour
constituer cette majorité alternative
moi je dis à celles et ceux qui veulent
venir là constituent avec nous vous êtes
les bienvenus mais c'est à eux se
positionner sur le sujet parce que pour
l'instant quand on s'est adressé à
europe ecologie les verts par courrier à
deux reprises nous n'avons eu aucune
réponse que pour l'instant le parti
socialiste a toujours dit que tout ça
soit il ne pouvait pas être question de
gouverner la france a soumis j'ai
entendu d'autres dirigeants politiques
du parti socialiste depuis dimanche soir
le dire et j'ai observé que dans le
discours de l'ensemble des candidats de
gauche dimanche soir aucun d'entre eux
ne s'est adressé à nous aucun d'entre
eux n'a juste reconnu la dynamique qui
s'était exprimé en notre faveur donc
voila moi je dis d'abord la balle est
dans leur camp nou en tout cas les
choses sont claires l'ont toujours été
tous celles et ceux qui veulent
gouverner
écoutez ne pas un cas je sais pas quand
on fait 22 % des voix au premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle je pense qu'on
a incarné une capacité de rassemblement
quand on a constitué ce qu'on a appelé
le parlement de l'union populaire avec
des figures issues du monde associatif
des figures issues du monde syndical des
personnalités du monde de l'art et la
culture qui sont regroupés autour de la
candidature de jean luc mélenchon si on
incarne le rassemblement le problème
c'est sans doute que le sujet est moins
aujourd'hui le rassemblement des
étiquettes ou des appareils que le
rassemblement des électrices et des
électeurs est ce qu on a constitué dans
l'élection présidentielle c'est une
forme de rassemblement voilà et donc
maintenant c'est cette forme de
rassemblement qui va falloir
et vous dites on veut on veut
on veut prendre le pouvoir finalement
est-ce que vous être en capacité d'avoir
une majorité à l'assemblée
c'est dans cet objectif là que nous
travaillons en tout cas et c'est
pourquoi je vous dis que celles et ceux
qui veulent participer à la constitution
de cette majorité alternative sont les
bienvenus mais que la balle est dans
leur camp et que pour l'instant ils ont
toujours écartés ou refuser les montes
que vous du coup vous êtes prêt à vous
retirer derrière un candidat europe
ecologie les verts derrière un candidat
ps si celui ci est mieux placé dans une
circonscription mais on verra mais si on
fait une forme d'accord de rassemblement
nécessairement ça veut dire qu'il ya un
endroit plus important dans lequel c'est
la france a soumis smic ont dû ce
rassemblement et à un autre endroit où
c'est un candidat communiste où un
candidat écologiste par exemple qui
conduit ce sera sa tâche a
proportionnellement vos résultats de la
présidentielle pour vous la répartition
des circonscriptions si vous arrivez à
un accord nécessairement bon on va pas
rentrer ici dans la tambouille mais les
rapports de force telle qu'ils soient
issus du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle c'est à dire tel qu ils
ont été déterminées par les électrices
et les électeurs doivent être une
boussole pour un éventuel rassemblement
j'imagine que si acoria pour vous il
peut pas être ça ne peut pas être un
accord purement électoralistes ce serait
aussi un accord sur le fond pour il ya
des choses qui vous voulez plus
particulièrement négocier que vos
partenaires ou pas moi je pense qu'on
n'est pas dans cette optique là c'est à
dire si vous voulez le programme c'est
plutôt dans le sens qu'il faut poser la
question j'ai dit pour constituer une
majorité
je m'adresse et je tends la main les
chancelleries de la société c'est
l'avenir encore ces crimes forcément en
tout cas c'est la base de 2,2 de ce
rassemblement ensuite si telle ou telle
composante nous dit oui mais nous on a
un problème sur tel sujet on peut en
parler d'ailleurs je rappelle quand même
que pendant l'élection présidentielle
on a tendu la main aux communistes en
leur disant travaillons ensemble à la
présidentielle est obligé de négocier
sur vos bases oui mais je joue je
termine ma phrase quand on a tendu la
main on a dit si la question du
nucléaire puisque on savait que c'était
un sujet de débat avec fabien roussel
pose question on peut s'engager sur un
référendum c'est pour vous donner un
exemple mais clairement la base doit
être la base qui a été choisi par les
électrices et jean luc mélenchon et
fabien roussel se sont parlés depuis
premier toit
je ne le sais pas pour être tout à fait
honnête j'imagine que ce qu'ils ont
vocation à se parler dans les jours qui
viennent mais jean-luc mélenchon est la
vocation à parler avec eux avec tout le
monde mais vous savez les gens ils sont
là c'est je crois des discussions dans
les couloirs des discussions opaque où
il faut être transparent il me semble
que ce que je dis est clair et
transparent publiquement ces discussions
elles doivent se faire sur la place
publique pas dans les couloirs parce que
sinon les gens ne comprennent pas
question manuellement par vous serez
candidat aux législatives sans doute on
n'a pas encore où sa maman je ne sais
pas encore en tout cas moi je suis
parlementaire européen je suis satisfait
de mon mandat mais mes et si je dois le
poursuivre je le poursuivrai grand
plaisir maintenant effectivement c'est
une échéance qui m'intéresse le temps
vers marseille c'est plutôt dans le sud
mais je sais pas encore dans le sud
merci beaucoup merci manuel vont pas
d'avoir été notre invité la une d'ouest
france présidentielle de france
s'opposent et se font face c'est à la
une de votre journal stéphane merci
madame
[Musique]